ils étaient cinq cents 500 chefs
d'entreprise pour mettre à l'honneur une
vingtaine de lauréats
le but de l'événement est de récompenser
des jeunes entreprises et surtout de les
mettre en lumière pour créer du lien une
initiative que daniel herrero parrain de
l'événement et ancien joueur du rugby
quinze de france approuve le principe
général du fonctionnement de ce club
d'entreprises c'est d'être ensemble
entre eux des gens qui ont déjà de
l'expérience qu'ils ont les rudesses du
monde digérer qui ont les capacités a
pas baissé les jets dans les tempêtes
ces gens là bas ils tendent la main etc
réduire leur créer du lien après après
le lien et la différentes intensités la
différentes chaleurs et c'est pour cette
raison que la société e dts une société
d'ingénierie automobile a décidé de
faire partie du réseau entreprendre base
est attrapé créé il ya un an
l'entreprise a besoin de tisser des
liens avec le monde de l'entreprise %
posé sur le bassin dans un premier temps
c'était effectivement que financier mais
dans la second temps
réseau entreprendre ça ça vous sort de
l'innovation d'un chef d'entreprise ça
vous permet d'avoir une famille une
appartenance à un groupe
et puis surtout ça nous permet de
collaborer sur d'autres projets ensemble
donc il ya il ya plein d'aspects
positifs à et à raison entreprend
d'ailleurs la société e dts a fini parmi
les 20 lauréats de l'événement son
business plan a séduit le jury
la chef d'entreprise est donc reparti
avec 30000 euros une somme qui lui
permettra de recruter des salades